the beginnings of this album it began
with a gift
from a fan is this right yes it began
with this guitar
right here a guy i was coming out of my
play
on broadway and uh
you know you come out and there's a
small group of fans and you sign some
things and talk to some people and
and there was a kid standing there or a
guy standing there with this guitar and
he just handed it to me i thought he
wanted me to sign it
he said no no it's it's for you it's for
you i want you to i want you to have it
you know and so
i jumped in the car with it i didn't
look much at it till i got home and then
when i got home i looked at it and i
realized
it was a gorgeously gorgeous it's a
gorgeously made
made piece the wood is beautiful and
it's just uh
and so i left it in my living room and
uh
when i started to feel like writing i
just picked it up and i
it sounded so beautiful i i most of the
songs from the record came out of it so
i owe a debt to uh to my mysterious
friend who handed me
handed this to me on the street in new
york city
because looking looking at the room i
sort of think if i was gift shopping for
bruce springsteen
i probably wouldn't have gone for
[Laughter]
i'm always guitar i'm always glad to
have another guitar